気づいたの最近でした
僕たちはご飯を食べに行こうと思ってい
何気なく
家の周りの道町
歩いていましたから
そうだな結局実際実際そういうところあり続くないですよっと
グリーン
8そのですが家の近くまで来るという
軽い返事だけだということです
私は気づいたのです
pane
どうした源さん
んだよこれ
無数の手形が私の家の壁に残っていたのです
ついていた手形をとても高い位置に付いてい
とても
人間してるじゃん
届かない場所についていますか
[音楽]
僕たちはドン引きして
ドン引きしただけでした
[音楽]
しかも今日は外れ社長です今観ていただいた動画なんでまでイメージ動画なんですけど
も実際にあった話ですねあの手の跡も本物でございます
長崎
ありガッツだよねが
がちなんですよ逆に逆に言うと逆に僕がもしあれをやらせるんだったらなんか血の跡と
かつけてやります
[音楽]
何の話誰がやったかもわからないけどおそらくなんですけども誰かが僕の家に
よじ登ろうと吸ってたのかなという予想はしておりますねマジ怖かったですよ地時代
あれを見たときましてこうだったですから誰誰誰誰だってこの動画を見ている
ちょっとだけ書くかも知れませんからねってほぼその確率が高いです
君
君望この動画を見ている誰かがひょっとして僕チームに来て家の風呂として僕家に侵入
しようとしたっていうことが今ありました masaki さん怖くないですか
結構笑えなくないそれであのなんかて方がついていたがおっしゃるんですけどもあれ
多分僕が本気でジャンプしても届かない場所です
実際に飛んでみたんですけどまずあの高さまで届かなかったんで何で箸事が使ったのか
ね
はしごか何かによってジャンプしたに家の bot にして知ってたのかなっていう気
はしていますマジ怖
いや笑い事じゃないって本当ほんとうと笑えないからね結構怖いからねあの
止めてくださいね同伴でれもう色々ちょっと大家さんそうな島アップしているので知ら
ないとか家にこれでの本当に why ことです
ごく当たり前のこと言ったら今強いことなのでよかったら皆さんよかったらではあり
ません家の建物をよじ登ろうとするのはやめてくださいという音接近混ぜてゾッとした
しすごい怖かったなっていう話がしたかったです
それだけ
ええええええ
ああああああ
あっ
います
なんだよこれ
おっ